l'homme ça bouge nous sommes au théâtre
de saint lô ce soir pour une pièce qui
s'appelle little boy avec notamment
christophe alévêque et on y parle
d'hiroshima génériques
le générique on vient d'entendre ces
enola gay orchestral manoeuvres in the
dark s'imposer c'est l'avion qui a lancé
vital boys boys boys étant la bombe qui
arrive sur hiroshima et vous vous êtes
celui qui fait les repérages avant que
cette bombe ne soit largué christophe
alévêque bonsoir et puis le régime comme
vous êtes celui qui écrit texte et vous
êtes un penseur dans la pièce vous
arrivez dans l'univers de ce personnage
un petit peu torturé et on le serait à
moins
et vous en faites une pièce qui à la
fois drôle et aussi forcément sur un
thème tragique alors votre personnage
commence avec vous christophe ils se
sont coupables forcément et c'est un
petit peu le thème de la pièce
sais tu suces est plus que coupable il
c'est à dire que la cent cinquante mille
morts à peu près sur la conscience donc
ça fait beaucoup quand même
et qui pourrait supporter
donc il est assailli de questions il a
absolument aucune réponse
si 1945 je fais partie de l'opération
papier sur hiroshima
je suis le commandant de l'avion de tête
l'avion météo nommée citoyenne flash
j'ai envoyé un message codé qui était à
esi largué nous avons détruit la ville
d'hiroshima ses 158 morts connaissez pas
vous savez même pas ce qu'on allait
faire
on savait même pas ce que c'était cette
bombe tout ce qui est dit dans la pièce
est vrai il a cambriolé des banques sans
rien prendre
il a changé de métier il était un peu et
un peu comme ça mais surtout quand j'ai
vu cette sept corps et enfin cette
rencontre épistolaire entre candeur et
claude et early joyet théâtralement tout
de suite c'est vrai ils devraient payer
de l'âge mais tout de suite ça m'a
évoqué un fou et un philosophe sur scène
sur une scène de théâtre déjà c'était
drôle
les instituts jour ils veulent faire
croire des choses comme ça comment
parler ton problème
une lumière derrière puisque c'est une
pièce je veux moi moi la première fois
que j'ai lu je pensais connaître
l'histoire d'hiroshima
et en fait non donc on apprend aussi d
des choses mais sans être lénifiant une
fois de plus
et la religion alors la danse en mission
hors electric en 2015 alors est il plus
de pavés là dessus sur la question et on
parle pas mal de ça puisque l'autre
était un américain qui a pu massacrer
plein de gens avec mais qui croit
fortement en dieu c'est une culture très
croyante et
et puis voilà parce qu'on parle beaucoup
de 2,2 de dieu roulement et d'islam en
ce moment mais ceux qui sont allés
largué la bombe sur hiroshima le ont été
bénis par voilà et son parti en disant
dieu dieu est avec vous ne l'oublions
pas non plus donc il n'y a pas d'un côté
les bons et de l'autre les méchants
l'histoire tourne à 7 1 cd cd cycle mais
les religions reste c'est eux c'est
étonnant
beaucoup de questions vous l'avez
compris dans cette pièce little boy à
voir ce soir donc au théâtre de salon
théâtre roger ferdinand
il reste encore quelques places alors si
vous voulez venir vous pouvez en
profiter puisque ça va commencer à 20h30
quelques places seulement mais vous
pouvez venir à saint lô merci beaucoup
christophe merci beaucoup régis là où ça
bouge à la fermeture éclair de caen pour
vous faire découvrir l'univers d'un
plasticien il s'appelle roma sagnet il a
fait les beaux arts à caen connaît bien
la fermeture éclair
il aime les polars le cinéma de jean
pierre melville romain saddier porte un
univers bien à lui
ce que j'aime avant tout c'est le sait
le collage le cinéma la bande dessinée
les choses on associe des images en fait
et enfin du travail à partir de
photoshop à partir de l'image trouver de
la soirée par fils c'est un art c'est
quelque chose de populaire et qui qui
est l'art populaire compte beaucoup pour
moi je vous ai parlé de bandes dessinées
de cinéma et ce sont des choses qui sont
très importantes pour moi que si les
matériaux que j'aime en sérigraphie en
dessin petit ou grand format roma
saddier aime aussi publié ses oeuvres
romain saddier un jeune graphiste à
découvrir jusqu'au 20 février à la
fermeture éclair de caen